(soft beat music)
Bitter sweetness is a view of the world,
and a way of being in the world.
It's a way to connection, it's a way to transcendence.
You're very attuned to the gap between the world as it is
and the world, as we would wish it to be.
You can take those pains and sit with them somehow,
and then make meaning out of them.
Here's a question for you,
are you one of those people that finds solace,
that finds comfort in things like,
rainy days or melancholy music?
If you know what I'm talking about,
that feeling isn't really a feeling of sadness,
it's more like this feeling of longing,
like this beautiful ache,
this ache that actually makes you feel
more connected to the human experience.
So what is that experience exactly?
Well, today's guest former corporate lawyer turned author,
wondered the same thing.
And so she went on like this seven year journey
to better understand it.
The result of which is "Bittersweet."
her number one New York Times bestselling book
that ponders this quiet state of being,
and why embracing it pays a true path
to things like creativity, deeper connection,
and ultimately transcendence.
I think you could say that quiet states of being,
are Susan Cain's thing.
They are her specialty,
because her first book was literally entitled, "Quiet,"
quiet, the power of introverts
in a world that can't stop talking.
That book spent eight years
on the New York Times bestseller list.
Her writing has appeared everywhere.
Her Ted talks on the power of introverts, and this idea of
bitter sweetness have been viewed over 40 million times.
And today she's here and no surprise,
we go deep on both these things,
introversion and bitter sweetness,
which I think we can agree are both states that
culture doesn't do a great job of encouraging.
And yet both are very powerful when recognized
and when nourished as these vehicles
for acceptance and for meaning and for connection.
So here we go,
please hit that subscribe button and enjoy me
trying to hide just how nervous I was,
and a bit intimidated I was, talking to Susan Cain.
I was thinking about you the other day,
because I got invited to attend this conference
down in San Diego.
And I was looking forward to it like,
oh, I get to actually just relax and be an attendee
as opposed to getting on stage.
Yeah.
Which is very to this day, anxiety producing in me.
And then at the last minute
it was being put on by Sanja Gupta at CNN.
And he texted me and he's like,
"Oh, by the way, I think it would be great if you did
"like a fireside chat with Lance Armstrong,
"like on Thursday or whatever."
And I immediately went from like,
thinking this was a little bit of a mini vacation.
Yeah, totally.
Suddenly like, oh my God, how am I gonna do this?
Like tormenting myself and being tortured
over the whole thing.
Because no matter how many times I've graced a stage,
it still feels very unnatural to me,
and is still very anxiety producing.
Yeah, I know exactly what you're talking about.
You probably know I used to have this huge public speaking
phobia so for me it used to be like,
a completely destabilizing event.
So I'm totally past that now, like that's overcome,
but I still completely relate to what you just said.
Like if I'm in the audience and going to the conference,
it's like la, la.
But it waking up in the morning
when I have to be the one on stage,
it's just like, that's not a chill morning.
Yeah.
Well, the occasion of this conversation is
your latest book "Bittersweet."
But I do wanna spend a little bit of time
on the introversion subject matter.
Yeah.
Because I relate to it so deeply as somebody
who has come into an awareness of being
an introvert or on the introversion side of that spectrum.
But somebody who can emulate the extrovert for short bursts
or periods of time, but always has to retreat
to charge the battery back up.
Right, yeah, we should definitely talk about that.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, no, I get it completely.
Yeah, so I'm interested in how you...
It's so interwoven with the public speaking thing too,
which is fascinating
It is so interwoven.
Yeah.
Well, not for every introvert,
'cause there are introverts who are totally comfortable
with public speaking.
It's like some small subset of them feel that way.
But for most people they more describe what you just did.
Yeah.
But even extroverts probably fear it on some level.
Is that the case?
Oh, lots of extroverts fear it.
Yeah, I mean it's like the number one fear.
So there's tons of extroverts who are terrified of speaking.
Yeah, and what's interesting about your work,
when we talk about quiet and introversion,
which is a subset of the population,
albeit a larger one than I think we previously realized,
"Bittersweet" speaks to something that's universal
in all of us, not just to that subset,
but on some level to everybody.
But I think what unites these books,
or one thing that unites them,
is that they both are this call to elevate something
that society undervalues or doesn't quite understand
and often, to our detriment squashes out of us.
Yeah, yeah.
And so that's kind of this universality theme
that permeates your books,
like what is that sensibility like,
how did you come into that?
I'm interested in like how you chose this subject matter
and why this has become your calling.
Yeah, absolutely, we can talk about that.
I think about it also, it's exactly what you just said,
like hidden superpowers.
And it's also about a different way of being in the world
from the one that is celebrated,
in the media and celebrity culture,
and all of it in our work culture.
I would say both of the books are about a different way
of being in the world.
Yeah, I mean, I'm just interested in
the Genesis of all of this for you.
I know it's interwoven with public speaking
and maybe we can begin with the introversion question
like this appreciation of introversion in yourself
and this kind of quest or desire to dig deeper
into what that means and how,
what you discovered could be healing
to the many, many people who are introverts
and feel out of step with cultural expectations
or a sense of who they feel like they should be or could be.
Yeah, I don't know where this comes from in me,
but I would say when I wrote "Quiet"
and when I wrote "Bittersweet,"
I thought that I was writing two really different books.
But now when I look at them,
they both have to do with the way in which
culture has such a specific and really rather narrow
expectation of the way
that we're supposed to be in the world.
And so both books are talking about a different way of being
and one that is quite powerful
or ways that are quite powerful in their own, right?
That don't get celebrated and kids from a very young age,
like in the case of introversion are taught,
you should be out there, you should be dominant.
You should be loud, you should be take charge.
This whole constellation of qualities, which are wonderful,
but there's another way of being that describes
a third to a half of the population.
And that brings with it delights and powers of its own.
And it just felt to me like,
colossal waste of talent and energy and happiness
to be telling up to half the population
that who you are isn't okay
and you should be turning yourself into a pretzel
to be some other way.
Right, right.
And so how do you define that?
Like what is your definition of introversion?
And I suppose the follow up question to that is like,
how does that differentiate from someone who is shy
or somebody who is insecure,
or has some kind of social anxiety.
Yeah, so introversion is about,
I mean, there's a kind of popular definition,
which I think works really well of like,
where do you get your energy from?
And a really easy way to think of it is,
to imagine that you're at a party
and you've been there for about two hours
and it's with company you're truly enjoying,
and you're having a good time,
but still, the extrovert at the party,
their battery is charging up and now they want more,
whereas an introvert's battery is probably draining
no matter how good a time they're having.
And so there comes that moment where you just wish
you could beam yourself home and be someplace else.
And so it really is this question of like,
how much stimulation do you need in order to feel
in a state of peace and equilibrium?
And for introverts,
they get very quickly to a place of too much.
And for an extrovert,
you get very quickly to a place of too little.
Like if things are too quiet, not enough is happening,
you feel like, I better call a friend,
I better do something.
And all of that is quite different from shyness,
which is more about the fear of social judgment.
A shy person looks has an interaction with someone
who might have a neutral expression on their face
and they'll tend to read disapproval into the neutrality,
and then be very upset about the disapproval.
So it's a quite different state.
Like you could be an introvert and not be shy or vice versa.
But my work, I would say focuses on both,
both ways of being,
because both ways of being show up very similarly
in terms of behavior.
And so they get judged in similar ways.
Right, right.
And shyness being something that is mutable,
but perhaps introversion or extroversion is more
fundamental or constitution.
Like is there immutability to it?
Yeah, I don't know if I'd say that
one is more immutable than the other.
I would say in both cases,
there are temperaments that people are born with
that predispose you in one direction or another,
and then layered over the temperament,
you have all kinds of life experiences
and skills that you gain and it's all a big mishmash.
But Dev there are babies who are born
into this world and from the day they're born,
you can test their nervous systems and see that
they're more reactive to all different kinds of stimulation.
Like they'll salivate more if you give them sugar water,
and put it in their mouths.
And so the babies who salivate more
when they're two years old,
and you put them into a playgroup of kids,
they've never met before,
those are the babies who are gonna tense up
and take longer to integrate into the group
because they basically have a nervous system
that is just reacting more to new inputs,
and it makes you wanna like slow things down and pause
and check it all out right before you're ready.
When I think about that,
the word that comes to mind is sensitivity, right?
Which is applicable to bitter sweetness too.
Like I took your quiz.
I scored a 7.3.
So I guess I'm prone to some level of bittersweetness,
but I've always thought of myself as maybe
just a little bit more sensitive than certain other people,
and sensitivity could be a word that you could apply
to introversion as well.
Like they're just more sensitized to their environment or,
I mean, is that a completely different
way of thinking about this?
Or how does that work out?
No, it's more like these are all
really overlapping categories.
They don't lay totally on top of each other,
but they overlap.
So with bittersweetness, which by the way,
I define as a kind of a state of mind where
you're very attuned to the way in which
joy and sorrow in this world are forever paired.
You don't get one without the other in this life,
and the way in which everyone and everything we love
will not be here forever.
But that's somehow what comes with that knowledge,
there comes a kind of deep joy at the beauty of the world.
So it's like a real blend of all these deep instincts.
And what we found, we have a bittersweet quiz.
I say we, 'cause I developed it with Scott Barry Kaufman.
I know you know.
Yeah, I'm seeing him on Friday night.
Oh, that's right, I know.
He actually was inviting me to come,
but I'll be back home by then.
So Scott Barry Kaufman and I, and David Hiden,
who's at John's Hopkins.
We developed this quiz to measure how bittersweet you are.
And what we found is that the people
who score high on the quiz like you,
also score high on this trade of high sensitivity
that you're talking about kind of instinctively.
And that trait is basically like the kind of person
who just reacts much more intensely to everything.
Like if you see the beauty of these canyons out here,
like you're gonna really love it.
And if there were suddenly loud and terrible noise,
it would probably bother you that much more.
And so many introverts are highly sensitive,
but not all of them.
So we actually didn't find that there's any correlation
between bitter sweetness and introversion,
the correlation is with sensitivity.
Yeah, that's really interesting.
Yeah, yeah.
'Cause you would think that they would toggle together.
Well, it's like about 80% of highly sensitive people
are introverts,
but you could be highly sensitive and be extroverted also.
And then you could be introverted and not be sensitive.
So that's why I say these are like overlapping categories.
I'm interested in how we arrived
at this moment in our culture,
and you've written about this,
where I wouldn't say we pathologize introversion,
but we certainly don't like socially select for it.
Introverts are sort of thought of as
the people who are gonna have a harder time
in the workplace achieving,
they tend to have more difficulty getting their ideas across
because of the constructs that we've created around
education and professional careers.
And you've written extensively about like
how we've gotten to this point
and how we might rethink these cultural morays
or priorities to better understand,
not just this dynamic between introversion and extroversion,
but also like how to leverage the beautiful talents
of the introverts so that they can thrive because,
just like extroverts, they can become leaders.
And they're often the people with the most
interesting creative forward thinking ideas.
Yeah, and so there's this real mismatch.
I mean, when you look at who have been
many of the most creative people over time,
I mean, like psychologists have studied this,
and you usually find people who are quite introverted
or at least to some degree introverted,
because solitude is such a key ingredient of creativity,
which is not something that ever gets talked about,
but it's true.
Yeah, and for me,
I think I was just aware of this mismatch
from a really early age
because I come from a family of introverts.
Like I don't think we have a single extrovert
in my family of origin.
And it was just really plain to me that the different things
that my family members were doing in the world,
things that I admired were so related to
their kind of quiet and cerebral way of being.
I had a father who he was a doctor
and a medical school professor,
and he was amazing at what he did.
And he was the one you'd go to
if you couldn't figure out the diagnosis,
he might be able to figure it out.
And he was also somebody who would work these long hours
and then he would come home after work
and pour over medical journals,
and like go to the medical conferences
and sit in the front row and tape everything
and listen to it over and over again
until he'd figured it out.
And it was things like that I kept seeing in real life,
and then many of the artists I admired
and writers I admired.
So just like people out in the world
were so clearly contributing, not in spite of,
but because of their quieter way of being.
And yet, as you're saying,
in our schools and in our workplaces,
it's not thought of that way.
Right.
And so what is the solution for that?
I know you've done a lot of work around like reorienting
the workplace and trying to find ways where we can
foster that type of energy and bring it to the surface
and in a way where it is respected better.
I mean, I do think as with everything,
that raising awareness is the hugest step of all.
And it's actually been amazing to see
how over the last 10 years,
how much more awareness there is,
and how much of a shift in orientation there is.
So there are lots of workplaces that are like
thinking about this in really conscious terms.
And they have work in groups formed around it.
And they're thinking through different ways of hiring
and promotion and that kind of thing.
And you also see schools doing things
like rethinking the way kids are given feedback.
'Cause so many kids are told,
like Sophie is doing great academically,
but she must learn to speak up more in class.
And getting that feedback compared to,
Sophie is a deep thinker and when she contributes,
everybody turns around to listen
because she has so many interesting insights to add.
That feels completely different to Sophie.
And I've gotten a lot of letters from Sophies of the world
telling me of how painful it is to them
when they get the first type of feedback.
They feel like their teachers don't respect them at all.
So I am seeing those kinds of changes.
We are seeing those kinds of changes,
and that's really gratifying,
even though I think we have a long way to go.
I just know for myself, when I think about
open floor plan workplaces or co-working place
that sounds terrible to me.
Like I want a womb, I wanna shut the door.
I don't want any windows.
I don't want anybody to ever knock on that door
or for the phone to ring.
Like my great ambition is to be left alone.
And when I can inhabit that place,
I then can do the work that I feel compelled to do,
my best work.
But anything that involves collisions or like inter,
just sounds like a nightmare to me.
And when I see that trend of like these open floor plans,
like that doesn't seem conducive to the introvert,
like being able to express themselves optimally.
Oh, my God, yes.
And in fact, I discovered this because,
well, like you, I used to be a corporate lawyer.
So I had come from this world,
I assume your firm was like this where
everyone had their own little office.
It was almost like a dorm room or a dormitory
with everybody in their office.
So I kind of thought that's what work looked like.
And then I started researching "Quiet."
So I decided I was gonna like plop down in Silicon valley
for a while,
because I figured there would be many introverts there.
And I was expecting this kind of introvert Nirvana.
When I got there,
and all these people who I was interviewing,
they're all coming up to me and kind of whispering like,
this open office plan that I'm in is a disaster,
and I can't concentrate.
Like everything that you just said.
Everything's overwhelming.
And they were like, I can't tell my boss.
This is why they're whispering.
They're like, I can't tell my boss because
if my boss heard me saying this,
they would think I'm not a team player.
They think I don't like my colleagues.
And it's not that it's just, it's everything you just said
about the best way that they would feel would focus
and be in a state of equilibrium
would be in private environments.
So they start asking me like,
is there research that I could show my boss
to just let them rethink this a little bit?
And I started looking,
and this was like a long time ago.
But even by then, there was a lot of research.
There was a mountain of research showing all the problems
with these open office plans specifically for introverts,
but really for everyone.
Focus goes down, and people get more sick, all this stuff.
So fast forward,
I would say now people are starting to understand
how problematic that kind of floor plan is.
And especially now in the wake of the pandemic,
there is a kind of rethinking going on.
Where we end up remains to be seen,
because it's also much more cost efficient
to have everybody crammed into one big space.
Sure, of course.
The pandemic must have provided you with a lot of data
on this, like on one level,
it's sort of Nirvana for the introvert who now
can be (indistinct) in their own home
and can sort of control their environments
a little bit better, but then over time, maybe not so good.
Like what have you learned about the pandemic in terms of
the introversion extroversion thing
in the workplace, et cetera.
It's a little bit of a mixed bag because,
as you're suggesting, there's a way in which,
especially during kind of peak lockdown,
there's a way in which it was much easier for
your typical introvert than for your typical extrovert,
but all the uncertainty that was involved and the disruption
isn't easy for anyone and introverts in general,
are less comfortable with uncertainty than extroverts are.
So I would say it took a toll in different kinds of ways,
but what I really saw is that,
excuse me, especially at that moment,
it was really a fantastic time,
regardless of who you were to take stock,
or regardless of your temperament,
to take stock of whether your previous life
had been working for you or not.
'Cause, I knew many extroverts who were telling me,
you know what, even for me,
I was going to 24/7 and now I realize that
I wanna pull this back.
And then there were introverts who were saying,
this is fantastic.
And I love not having to go to the office all the time
and I have to rework my life to preserve some of this.
Yeah, I think
we're gonna be learning about this for years to come.
Like we're still kind of in it and we don't necessarily have
the 10,000 foot view on the long term impact of this,
but it's been hard for everybody.
It's been very hard on you and your family, I know that.
And must have been excruciating for you
while writing this book on bitter sweetness to,
kind of endure loss in your own family.
Yeah, that was an interesting thing because
people assume that I wrote "Bittersweet,"
like in response to the disruptions
and the losses of the pandemic,
because as you say, I lost my brother first
and then my father to COVID,
but I was actually working on this book
for years before that.
That is my way, I work on things for a really long time.
So I don't know,
what's interesting to me about that is,
I see the world as bittersweet all the time,
and I'm like, regardless of what's going on,
so when it's a pandemic, it's not surprising to me.
And the epigraph of the book comes from
the Leonard Cone quote of "There's a crack in everything"
and that's where the light gets in.
So because of seeing the world that way,
it means when we're in difficult times,
I'm also more apt to be looking for what the light side is
just as when we're in good times, I'm like,
come on, you guys, don't you realize everything is not
as perfect as you think.
There's also all this loss and fragility
going on at every moment.
It's a kind of worldview
where you're seeing it all constantly.
Well, it's a non-binary non-dualistic approach, right?
It's a very holistic approach to how emotions operate,
and you can't have one without the other,
and this is a soup and the more that we can appreciate
that one doesn't happen without the other,
the more kind of space there is for healing
and kind of understanding the beauty and the power
of leaning into these emotions rather than avoiding them,
because we're constantly being signaled to just be happy
or pursue happiness at all times, at all costs.
Right, right.
Yeah, and in fact,
I gave a talk about bitter sweetness at Ted the summer
before the pandemic hit.
So it was the summer of 2019.
And it was really interesting because,
I felt like there were half the people,
like when I came offstage and I knew a whole bunch of people
in the audience and half of them were like,
oh my gosh, this is totally me,
and I totally understand what you're talking about.
And then some of them were like,
oh, I didn't know that you were depressive.
And I was like,
no, that's actually not what I'm saying at all.
And that's
part of the problem that our culture has is that
we don't have a way of distinguishing between,
clinical depression,
which I would never recommend to anybody,
versus this way of being that takes it all in,
the good and the bad and is just aware of it all.
Right.
It's very telling that somebody would just leap to that.
Yeah.
And associate those two things as being the same,
and pathologizing it, right?
Oh my, I'm sorry, something's wrong with you,
as opposed to this is life.
And of course we aspire to live happy lives,
but that happiness is informed by the inevitable obstacles
and painful moments that descend upon all of us
and the manner in which we're able to kind of
embrace those moments, learn from them, lean into them,
I think enriches the happier moments because
that's truly how you appreciate life
rather than running away from those other things
and repressing them and trying to dodge them.
Yeah, and that there's this whole...
Like if you look at all our wisdom traditions
and our literary and artistic heritages,
across the world, across the centuries,
like they have been teaching all this time that
this is a way in that
that appreciating this side of existence,
the bittersweet side of existence is a way to creativity,
it's a way to connection, it's a way to transcendence.
And the way that I got into this whole inquiry
in the first place is because,
all my life I had had this really intense reaction
to sad music.
But by intense, I don't mean intensely sad.
I mean like I'd hear this music
and feel completely uplifted.
So there's this one moment I was in law school,
and some friends were picking me up in my law school dorm
on the way to class.
And I was blasting Leonard Cohen or something,
as I want to do.
And my friends came by and they thought it was hilarious.
And they were like,
why are you listening to this funeral music?
And at the time I just laughed and went to class.
And that was the end of the story.
But I couldn't stop thinking about it because it was like,
well, what is it in our culture that makes it so odd
to listen to this music, but even more,
what is it that the music is telling us?
There's something in it.
I mean, we know that sad music is much more likely
to produce like goosebumps and chills and listeners,
people listen to the happy songs on their playlists
175 times, but they listen to the sad songs 800 times.
And there's somewhere that that music is pulling us,
it's like that the musician is telling you
that thing that you felt,
that pain that you've sometimes felt,
I, the musician have been there too.
And everybody listening to this has been there too.
And we are all connected in this same
strange state of being human.
And that's where the feelings of uplift and love come from.
Right, and connection of course>
And connection.
You feel like you're seen and you're being heard.
There is somebody else there through a musical note
can identify very specifically in emotion
that you're experiencing
and suddenly you don't feel alone anymore.
Yeah, exactly.
And that's a joyful experience,
even if it's one that also is kind of
about sorrow and pain and grief.
Right, because I think the ultimate human desire
is for connection, and that's what it's doing.
And so, you look at our culture now
and there's so much divisiveness and so on.
And I don't think that's unrelated to the way in which
we're supposed to present
so cheerfully and so successfully all the time,
that means we're not really able to connect with each other.
Right.
Right, 'cause we're fronted and we're wearing that mask
and we're trying to,
appear or present in a certain way to be approved of,
or to be received in a manner that we would desire,
and that ultimately just alienates us from one another.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
I tend to look at these things,
and I've said this many times before,
as somebody who's been sober for a long time,
through the lens of recovery and,
the more that I was reading your book,
the more I couldn't help but think about
how this operates in the 12 step context,
because you're part of this community that has
kind of a shared narrative about
the pain that they've endured
and the struggles that they've sort of overcome
to be in this place.
But then somebody has the courage to get up in front of
a group of people and share their pain
and their grief and their sorrow,
but do it with a level of levity
and also a level of specificity.
And I found the more specific it is,
the more universal it is.
I may not relate to the facts of that person's experience,
but I can relate to the emotional experience
that they've had and you can't help,
but feel incredibly bonded to this person
and to the group,
through the courage, and the pain, and the grief,
and the levity that makes it all this
soupy mess of emotions
that just make you feel more human.
Yeah.
As you were describing that,
what came into my mind is Darwin actually,
'cause Darwin was actually,
he was a really kind of gentle and melancholic
type of person.
So he's known for survival of the fittest,
but he was actually this guy who like,
he couldn't stay on the site of blood.
His father wanted him to be a doctor,
and he took one look at like what surgery looked like
and fled to the jungles of the Galapagos to look at Beatles.
And he noticed from very early on,
I mean, he was very aware of how cruel and violent
animals and humans could be with each other,
but he also noticed at the same time that
there's this impulse that mammals and humans have
that when they see another being in distress,
that they feel the distress themselves,
it just gets mirrored and it's happening
at a really like quick and pre-conscious level.
And he thought that that was
the strongest impulse of all in humans.
So people talk about how
he's known for survival of the fittest but,
you could equally talk about survival of the kindest.
And now we're seeing the fruits of that,
like 150 years later in the research,
like there's a guy named Dr. Kelner at Berkeley,
who does all this amazing research.
And he's found for example, that we all have a Vagus nerve,
which is the most important,
biggest bundle of nerves in our bodies,
regulates breathing and digestion.
And your Vagus nerve becomes activated
when you were in your AA group
and seeing somebody talk about their troubles,
if you felt that sense of like your heart opening up
or your throat closing or whatever it is,
that's partly your Vagus nervous is becoming activated
almost against your will.
It just happens.
And so to cut that off from each other,
the ability to relate to each other that way,
is cutting off one of our most basic ways of bonding.
Right, so there is this implicit,
like evolutionary advantage to indulging
in this kind of emotional landscape.
Yeah, I mean, even the word indulging,
I wouldn't think of it...
Allowing, yeah.
To allowing, exactly.
I mean, it actually comes from our need as mammals
to be able to take care of our young,
like you have to take care of a baby who's crying
and that's how they let you know that they need something
because we're primed to be able to do that,
that kind of radiates outward to our ability
to react to each other in general, in that way.
And we don't always get it right
but that is one deep aspect of being human.
And then neurochemistry tracks to the vagus nerve.
Yeah, exactly.
Which makes me think this is like deeply primal
dating all the way back.
Exactly, exactly.
And the vagus nerve is like one of the most ancient parts
of the human body.
So it's really fascinating.
Yeah, this idea of bitter sweetness,
I think most people think of it as an experience,
but you talk about it as like a state of being.
So distinguish those two things and how you arrived at that
point of view.
Yeah.
So I mean, it is an experience in the sense of,
like the moment where you're walking your child
down the aisle or something,
that is a quintessential bittersweet experience.
But there's also a view of the world
and a way of being in the world, that's quite bittersweet.
You could call it melancholic, except that word
in our culture is associated with clinical depression.
And that's not really what it means,
or it's not the way I'm using it.
So the bittersweet state of being is much more about,
it's a sense of that awareness of joy and sorrow,
and of fragility.
Aristotle 2000 years ago,
he has this question of why is it that
so many of our great poets, philosophers and politicians,
all have a melancholic temperament?
Like what is that?
So it's something about being attuned to the gap
between the world as it is,
and the world as we would wish it to be.
The emotional DNA of humans is like,
we come into this world with a sense that
there is a more perfect and beautiful world
that's out there somewhere to which we belong,
but we somehow find ourselves here instead.
Right.
It's the yearning and the longing,
like the idea that things could be better.
It's not a despairing per se,
but it's a sense that like we're in a certain place,
it could be better.
And the melancholic impulse is built out of like,
how to get from one to the other.
Yeah, and it's the heart of our creative impulse,
it's like a feeling of like, how do you get closer to that
perfect and beautiful world for which you were yearning.
The word longing, like it literally means to grow longer
and to reach for.
So there is a sense in which we are all reaching
to get to this other place.
And that's what propels us forward.
Like, historically, we've always known this,
it's really only recently that we've forgotten it.
So with the Odyssey Homer,
that whole adventure, it starts with Homer,
who's on a beach weeping for his homeland,
'cause he's so homesick and because he's so homesick,
he goes out into the water and has this adventure.
It's the same thing with all our religions,
like we're longing for the garden of Eden,
we're longing for Mecca, we're longing for Zion,
and all the religions that like the teaching is that
it's through the longing that you get closer
to the divine itself.
So it's an incredibly generative state.
Right, and it's about temporality as well.
This idea of fragility and nothing lasts forever.
And we're only here for a short period of time,
and that ticking clock, kind of Memento mori,
is sort of a driver behind this state as well.
Absolutely, absolutely.
I actually tried practicing Memento mori,
while I was writing the book.
So like Memento mori, it basically means remembering death,
as a way of like understanding how precious life is,
and that idea comes to us from many different traditions.
So I tried it and I actually found it
to be so incredibly helpful.
And the place I really noticed it is like,
my kids at the time were pretty little
and we had this bedtime ritual that we were doing.
And it was an amazing time of day.
And it was like reliably the time that they would open up
about whatever was on their minds, and it was just great.
And I also was bringing my cell phone into the room
while I did that, while we would do bedtime.
I would say to myself,
they may not be here tomorrow, you may not be here tomorrow.
You have no idea.
And just that thought
would completely extinguish any desire I had
to look at the cell phone, like was gone.
And I stopped bringing it into the room completely.
And it didn't feel sad,
it didn't feel depressing, it was just a reminder.
Right.
That for me, connects to gratitude,
like if I can be present
that's what I'm trying to cultivate.
It's not necessarily a bitter sweetness other than like,
oh my goodness,
if this is the last time that I'm able to do this,
there's a dusting of sadness on that, I suppose.
It's complicated.
Like how to tease all this stuff out.
No wonder it took you so long to write this book.
Just trying to wrap my head around like what it is,
and what it isn't, how you cultivate it,
how to channel it appropriately.
Well, do you know the feeling I'm talking about
when you listen,
I don't know what kind of music you love.
I mean, we all like many different kinds but-
I love Leonard Cohen and I know he's your spirit animal.
He's my spirit animal, it's true.
Yeah, no, I mean, it's just like...
I started out with that question of why sad music,
like what's so great about it?
And that seemed like a kind of narrow question.
I didn't really realize it was gonna become a whole book.
It was more that was a gateway question
into this whole state.
Right, but if you look at the musicians,
the great poets, the writers, all of the painters,
the ones that seem to resonate the most
are the ones who have
the capacity to kind of take these
seemingly conflicting emotional states
or the polarities of them and weave them in some way
that makes sense to us as humans,
but perhaps transcends our ability to like articulate.
And I think when you see it,
it's sort of like when you hear it, you know it,
when you see it, you know it.
You're not sure like why is it that the minor key
or these certain songs and the way that they're constructed,
cultivate that in ourselves?
I don't know if there's neurochemistry on that
or any science on that,
but it really is like, I know what that is,
I don't know why I know what that is.
It makes me feel a certain way that is,
perhaps seemingly off my optimal state.
And yet there's a comfort.
Like you talk about rainy days and things like that.
Like you kind of wanna languish in it.
Yeah, there's a comfort and there's a transcendence in it.
Leonard Cohen, the very first artistic act that he took
was when he was nine years old and his father died
and he took one of his father's bow ties and he wrote a poem
and he buried the bow tie and the poem
in the backyard garden of their family house.
And that was his first artistic act.
And it was like, he was kind of repeating that act
again and again, throughout his career,
there's a kind of like taking something painful
and then turning it into something else.
And I think that's like the real, in terms of how to live,
that's the real insight that this tradition gives us,
because it's kind of saying to us,
these moments are gonna come, these pains are gonna come.
You have two choices of what to do with them.
You can suppress it in some way and inevitably,
you're gonna take it out on yourself
in the form of depression or addiction or whatever it is,
or you're gonna take it out on someone else,
abuse, passive aggression,
or you can take those pains and sit with them somehow
and then make meaning out of them and transform them.
And that's something that we do so naturally.
Like after 9/11,
you suddenly see all these people signing up
to be firefighters, the spike of applications,
it goes way up.
After the pandemic, lots of medical school
and nursing school applications.
So people are like,
you would think they might be running away from things-
Towards the thing that is creating the pain.
Exactly, exactly.
But it's a way
of making sense out of it and making meaning of it,
and turning it into something better.
And I think that's one of our fundamental impulses
when we're at our best.
Right, like take your pain and transmute it,
turn it into a creative offering.
Yeah, and I use the word creative,
I mean, in a very good way.
I don't pain to painting.
Spend seven years writing a book, it can be anything.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, and that's really powerful and I've thought,
that made me reflect on my own life and realize that
without being consciously aware of it, like I've done that.
So there is something instinctual in us
that's drawn to that practice.
Like before you were in recovery,
do you think you were taking the other path or like?
Oh, I mean, before when I was indulging in my addiction,
no, I was running away from everything and repressing
all of those challenging emotions and medicating myself,
essentially, because those emotions were too painful
or I wasn't mature enough to really excavate them.
And I was at the behest of a powerful substance.
Yeah.
That it hijacked me.
And I think most recovering addicts,
will be able to relate to that.
And I think there's something interesting about
the recovery community and what you kind of learn is that,
there's something aspirational there, even in the attic,
like they're looking for
a higher experience of self and consciousness,
and they're doing it in a very self-destructive
and unhealthy way.
But at the very core of it is like,
there should be something better or I'm in pain,
and I'm reaching for something else.
And then when you get sober and you can continue to reach
in a healthier direction, people in recovery,
like I know so many people,
they're just amazing human beings,
because they've learned to take that pain and turn it into
some form of creative offering
that is healing for not only themselves,
but for a lot of other people.
(upbeat music)
Prophets walk among us,
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever,
that our world is populated by scores
of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share.
Those that we don't know who can teach us something new,
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling profits on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast,
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer,
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce the release
of my new book, "Voicing Change" volume two.
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation
of the magic, inspiration,
and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on the Rich Roll podcast.
The first edition of voicing change was a beautifully
rendered book worthy of display on any coffee table,
and volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication,
replete with interview excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography making for an exquisite companion
to the first volume or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit the wisdom
of your favorite everyday prophets,
and physically interact with the life changing ideas
contained with them.
"Voicing Change" volume two available now
while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only at richroll.com.
I wrote most of "Quiet" in this cafe
called Doma in Greenwich village,
which no longer exists tragically,
'cause it was my place.
Aw.
It was such a great place.
It just had this amazing creative energy
and people would come from all over
and work on their stuff there and get to know each other.
Every, I don't know if it was Tuesday nights
or Thursday nights or whatever,
but one or two nights a week,
it would happen that this group of people would come in.
And I always noticed them because they always had like
this special light about them.
There was a kind of charisma in them.
And then I found out that
they were all coming from AA meeting.
They were going for their coffee after the meeting.
Exactly, exactly.
Yeah, they had been meeting like right down the street.
There was something about this group that
you could feel reaching,
for transcendence or reaching for
the more perfect and beautiful world.
You could just feel it and they're very being.
And I think they were probably at a moment in their lives
where they were making the transition from doing that
in an unhealthy way to doing it in a meaning making way.
Yeah.
One of the more powerful aspects of that
is like making peace with that pain,
and kind of transcending the shame
that's associated with that.
And when you can kind of own it because you've unpacked it
and looked at it and shared it and worked through it,
that becomes a really powerful tool for continual growth,
but it requires like taking the blinders off,
and dealing with it.
And really the subtext of bittersweet
is for all of us to do that and appreciate,
all the colors of life and to really challenge ourselves,
to embrace these difficult emotions rather than
run away from them.
And the larger question that I'd love to hear from you on,
is like, how did we get to a culture that so forcibly,
pushes us in the direction of repressing so much.
Start with the Calvinists and like walk us through
like how we got to here and how we can kind of
grow and mature as a society
to have a healthier relationship with the nuance
and complexity of the human psyche.
Yeah, okay.
Well,
I'll start with like a glimpse of where we are right now,
and then I'm gonna go back in time.
So where we are right now,
our problem is that we look at ourselves and each other,
in terms of, are we winners or are we losers?
It's like this great binary and it's a kind of harsh binary.
And the word loser literally has gone up astronomically
in usage over the past decades.
But going back in time, so we started out
with Calvinism as the dominant religion,
and Calvinism, the idea was that
everybody was bound for either heaven or hell.
And you really had no choice of which direction
you were going in.
But what you could do was kind of demonstrate to yourself
and others that you were heaven bound,
and the way that you demonstrated that
was by being a really hard worker.
So everything was about labor and hard work.
But then like in the 19th century,
that started to transform as we became
more of a business culture,
it became more not so much how hard a worker are you,
but how successful are you at business,
or how much do you fail in business?
And then the question starts getting asked,
well, when you succeed or fail, what is the reason?
And with these echoes of Calvinism,
and Barbara Ari talks about this
in her book really brilliantly.
With these echoes of Calvinism
we answer the question by saying, you succeeded or failed
because of something inside you.
It's like, you're heaven bound, you're hell bound.
You're either a born success or a born failure.
And the more you start looking at things that way,
and really believing that,
the more you need to develop the emotional affect,
the emotional self presentation of somebody who's a success.
So you don't wanna talk about anything that suggests
an acquaintance with longing or loss
or fragility or memento mori,
you're not gonna talk about anything like that.
You are gonna be presenting in a really cheerful way and,
over the course of the 19th century
that became really explicit so that people stopped wanting
even to talk about bad weather,
like that was seen as not cool,
not appropriate to notice that there are clouds in the sky
literally, and that's kind of increased over time.
So then you get to the great depression in 1929,
and you have all these people who are losing all their money
because of external forces.
And some of them are committing suicide,
and they're described as losers in the journalism.
They're described as losers.
And that's the heritage that we're still living with now.
There's I think a deep fear that people have
of being a loser and a deep need to be a winner,
instead of seeing the actual truth of the situation
which is that in all lives there are successes and failures
and wins and losses, and that's just how it is.
Right, it's so interesting
that it emanated out of this heaven, hell binary.
Yeah.
Winners, losers, heaven, hell, rich, poor,
these binaries that put us in buckets
and allow us to judge each other.
Yeah, and to judge ourselves, to judge ourselves.
Probably more detrimentally, right?
Yeah.
When people start feeling like they're getting closer
to the loser side of that divide,
I think the fear and the shame in that is overwhelming.
But has that not even expanded?
Because now as we have moved even more towards this
self-help obsessed culture,
it's a happy, sad thing or a depressed, happy thing.
And we're afraid of people who are demonstrating,
challenging emotions and we're sort of repelled by them.
Like we move away from the person who's grieving
or the person who is depressed,
because we don't have a comfort level or a vocabulary
for how to communicate with them.
And there's this sense that it's contagious, right?
Like you can't be associated with that.
That's gotta go over there.
And even our relationship with death,
to bring memento mori up.
It's in a hidden corner and we don't talk about it,
and we pretend it's not gonna happen to us.
And we've sort of stripped it from
our kind of daily experience of life,
despite its inevitability.
And there is something pathological about that.
Oh, yeah.
And we allow people to grieve for a certain amount of time,
but then after that, there's something-
You're over it.
Yeah, that's really socially unacceptable-
And that's because it's making me uncomfortable
that you're still grieving.
Like I don't really wanna be around that.
I think it's that.
And I also think there's a way in which we judge.
There's something distasteful about it.
It's weakness.
I mean, yeah.
Like I think of the admiration that we have for people who,
they're like moving forward in a supposedly healthy way.
Like even in the most recent version of the DSM manual
in psychology,
they've now limited the amount of time for grieving,
I'm forgetting now the exact amount,
but it's like a very short amount of time
and then after that you're considered to have a diagnosis
if you're still in a state of grief for a loved one.
Right, that's so weird.
Yeah, and like in "Bittersweet," I tell the story of,
do you know Susan David?
I do.
Who I love.
Yeah.
So she's a dear friend of mine, she's a great psychologist.
And her work came out of her experience
when she was 14 and she lost her father to cancer.
Okay, and Susan is a really cheerful person by temperament.
That's like who she is.
So because of that, she felt all this cultural pressure
and 'cause she's so cheerful,
she put on a big show for the whole year
after her father died.
She like went to school, acted as if nothing was wrong.
Everyone would say, are you okay?
She was like, "Sure, I'm fine."
But in the meantime, she's off in the bathroom,
vomiting up her lunch every day.
So that's how it was coming out for her.
And she would've kept going on that way
until in her English class,
she had a teacher who had also lost a parent at a young age
and the teacher hands out blank notebooks to the class,
and she looks Susan straight in the eyes and she says,
"I want you to write down what you're truly feeling.
"And no one else is gonna read it except me.
"And I'm hardly gonna comment at all,
"but just write the truth,
"write the truth of your experiences."
And Susan said that moment for her,
it was like a revolution in a notebook.
'Cause it was like the only time she had been invited
to actually tell the truth,
and that was her healing.
And like that's what we don't do.
Right.
And that's what leads to this whole life of
exploring emotional resilience and how to develop it, right?
And certainly by repressing or running away
from these difficult experiences and emotions,
is to undercut our ability to develop
that level of resilience to weather the difficult times
that we all inevitably face.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
There's really interesting data on it.
That the more we have a sense of the fragility of existence,
the more of a sense of gratitude we have,
the less angry we feel,
the more we invest in meaningful relationships.
What I was fascinated by in the book
was you dipping your toe into the...
Sorry, I've got a frog in my throat.
Into the life extension world.
Yeah.
Like that sort of,
we're gonna live forever crowd.
Yeah.
And I know some of those people,
and I'm familiar with that kind of scene.
So walk me through that,
because there's so many profound,
philosophical questions that come up-
So many.
Psychological profiles that you could render
about the people who are obsessed with this,
that I think are not getting
an appropriate amount of attention or discussion.
Yeah, I agree with you.
And in fact, when I went to one of these conferences,
I was just assuming that there's gonna be
all kinds of philosophical discussion,
about whether this was a good idea or not,
or like what the downsides were.
No, it's totally Pollyanna on that.
Oh my God, no, no, no.
I mean, it's much more like,
thank goodness everybody here is beyond all those questions.
We don't have to talk about that, we know it's a good idea.
That's really the vibe.
Yeah.
I've had a couple people on the podcast
who are from that world and I can't help but think like,
philosophically, like what is your relationship to life
if you could live for 300 years?
Like how does that change the choices that you make,
the risks that you're willing to incur,
and the kind of relationships
that you're gonna have with people.
But that doesn't really seem to be of interest
to the people that are-
Well, I mean, they talk about it,
but they talk about it in a way
that resolves it very neatly.
Like they talk about terror management theory,
which is basically...
Okay, that's the idea that,
there are all these studies that show that
when we're reminded of our mortality,
that in the immediate aftermath of being reminded of it,
we become much more like focused on our in groups
and hostile to out groups.
So there's like studies where they'll remind people
of their mortality and then ask them how much hot sauce
they wanna put on the food that they're gonna give to
people in the opposing political party.
And people will put on too much hot sauce
'cause they get into this sort of anti out group mode.
So they take that and they say,
well, this means that
when we solve the problem of mortality,
we're also gonna be solving all our other problems
of conflict and war and everything else, 'cause it's like,
if we could solve this, we'll solve everything else.
And that's where I feel like,
I meant there's ways in which I'm actually
really sympathetic to the life extension project.
But I do feel like it's kind of missing
the larger point
that our problems are not only about the fact of mortality,
the problems are much deeper than that.
They have to do with
just all the longings of existence that would be here,
whether or not we lived forever.
Yeah.
Like they're still there, we're not gonna sidestep that.
And I think, of course there's something aspirational
about tackling this problem,
and it's fascinating to learn about it
and there have been these amazing breakthroughs in science,
et cetera.
But I can't help but think whether or not it's being driven
by just a deep seated fear of death
that's so desperate that we must solve this problem
because I don't wanna have to face that myself.
Well, I think they would actually,
in some ways agree with that.
I mean, part of the reason that I went
to see them and to study them was 'cause I was interested
just in this culture that we live in,
that wants everything to be like,
winning and sunshine all the time.
And I thought this would be a really interesting
example of that.
But what I actually found is all the scientists
would get up on stage and present their thing.
They would begin their scientific presentation
usually by telling a really heart winding story
of a person that they had lost in their lives,
and of how harrowing and how terrible
the bereavement had been.
And so they were like quite explicitly saying,
they were like, this is so terrible.
We just as a society should not be tolerating
this deep pain, we should be doing something about it.
So there was a way in which I was like really moved
because I felt like they were doing their own version of
taking a pain and trying to transform it
into something else.
And their something else is immortality itself.
Yeah, and what they would say, I think to your point is,
well, the idea that we have that there's a way in which
death or mortality gives us meaning to life,
that that's like a nice story that we tell ourselves
because we have no choice.
But if we really did have a choice,
then we might not be telling that story anymore.
Right, right, right.
And I'm not so sure about that.
Time will tell.
But it's funny that you say 300 years, 'cause I feel like,
300 years, that kind of sounds sort of plausible to me.
'Cause if you think about it,
we would have life expectancies of 35 or 40,
now it's 70 or 80 or whatever it is,
and we're totally comfortable with having doubled it.
But that's different from the achieving,
what is it called?
Life expectancy velocity or escape velocity.
Oh, yeah.
What is that longevity philosophy.
Something like that.
Where just basically every year you live like,
the extends the ability to extend the life.
Right, right.
Fortunately more or whatever.
So by definition
that means you could potentially live forever.
Right, theoretically, yeah.
We'll see, I don't know.
But on that subject,
that's not a distant cousin from this idea of transcendence.
And so I'm interested in how this dovetails into
a discussion around spirituality and religion,
these traditions of religion that relate to bittersweetness
that kind of percolate across all these different variations
of practice, I guess.
'Cause that's super interesting.
There is something (indistinct) about all of this.
Oh yeah, absolutely.
And I had no idea when I started off on this path
that I was gonna end up writing and thinking
so much about religion,
but I started realizing this whole subject is like
intricately bound up with that because
almost every religion that I see,
especially the mystical sides of our religions,
they're all talking about this state of longing
that all beings have for
union with a divine, essentially.
And the idea that the state of longing is actually
healthy in that way.
Like Rumi, the 12th century, Sufi poet,
he says, be thirsty.
And that the longing you express...
Well, he has this one poem where he is talking
about a man who's praying to Allah,
and he doesn't get an answer back.
And so he becomes kind of bitter and disappointed
and he stops praying.
And then he falls into asleep and he's not sleeping well.
And Hitter who's the guide of souls comes along to him,
and says, "Why did you stop praying?"
And the man says, "'Cause I never got an answer."
And the guide of soul says to him,
"The longing that you express that is the return message.
"And the grief that you cry out from
"is exactly what draws you towards union."
And so this is the message that we get again and again,
from these traditions,
like the grief is what draws you towards
the ultimate love that you seek.
And the yearning,
it's almost like a spiritual or a Boris though,
because these things are a circle,
they're a cycle, right?
Like the yearning,
the answer that you seek is in the yearning itself.
Yeah, yeah.
It's really beautiful.
Yeah, and I don't think...
Well, I don't know.
I mean, maybe someone does, I wouldn't know,
but I don't know that we ever like actually get there
on this earth,
but there's something about the act of drawing closer
that is intensely satisfying.
Yeah.
And how did that exploration land for you as somebody
who kind of identifies as agnostic,
but you had this grandfather who was this beautiful rabbi.
Where did this lead you?
Well, it was really interesting for me because I grew...
Yeah, my grandfather was an Orthodox rabbi
and like, I really adored him, everybody did.
And he was like such a huge figure in my life.
And at the same time, I've always been deeply agnostic.
And didn't really honestly think that much about religion
once I became an adult,.
I was kind of dismissive of it, if anything.
I don't know, I started to realize that
the thing that I feel when I listen to sad music
and what someone else might feel,
and I do to some extent when I'm in nature
or something like that,
the way I see it is that they're all manifestations
of the same experience.
And for some people, they have that experience
through the language of the divine and religion.
And for others, they have it through music or art or sports,
or whatever it is, but we're all kind of reaching
for that same state.
And in fact, there's this (indistinct) parable
that I came across that talks about,
that there's a rabbi and he has a man in his congregation
who he notices is paying no attention at all.
And isn't really buying what the rabbi's saying.
And then the rabbi hums for the man a yearning melody,
a bittersweet melody, and the man listens.
And he says,
"Now I understand what you've been trying to tell me
"all this this time, because I'm feeling this intense,
"longing to be United with God."
And I read that and I was like, oh my God, I'm that old man.
Yeah.
That's Leonard Cohen for you.
Right.
And what is it about that minor key or that
musical sensibility that elevates the soul
and can't help but leave you wondering
whether there is something more beyond the senses.
Yeah, I think it's because it's touching
that sense that we all have of there being
some other place that we're reaching for.
You see it in like the "Wizard of Oz," right?
It's like, Dorothy's longing for somewhere over the rainbow.
You look at all our children's stories.
There's always the protagonist who enters the scene,
at the moment they become an orphan,
that's when the whole adventure begins.
Like the moment they're thrust into
the state of primal belonging.
So I think that's just tapping into a DNA that we all share,
although it manifests differently for each of us.
There's this idea that this shared proclivity towards
bitter sweetness allows us to understand
that we are one super organism,
but perhaps it extends beyond the vagus nerve, right?
Yeah.
Right, right.
And you who like you're exploring Judaism and Sufism,
and these various religions and mystical traditions.
And there are similarities that
they're very different in many ways,
but there are these similarities that unite them.
And from that, can one extrapolate,
some truth about the beyond or our relationship with
something more ethereal and non-material.
Yeah.
I don't know that exploring all this gives
definitive answers to any of these lifelong questions,
but for me,
it offers a kind of roadmap of how to live,
because what it does is it makes you notice
how incredibly miraculous everything around us actually is,
how sacred it really is,
whether you're an atheist or believer,
I'm just using those words, like the wonder of it all.
And you can enter into a relationship
with that kind of wonder.
That really it's a complete enhancement,
a really transformation of what life is like.
It's a better way to live.
It's a much better way to live.
The good news is you can cultivate it
in whatever tradition suits you.
Absolutely, absolutely.
There are so many paths towards that.
Yeah, and we actually found in that bittersweet quiz
that we did that people who score high in bittersweetness
also score high in states of
awe and wonder and spirituality.
It's not surprising.
What is the relationship between bittersweetness
and awe and wonder,
they're like two sides of a similar coin.
Are they not?
Yeah, they are because,
basically, they're both born of
a receptivity and a noticing of everything that is.
So you're not only noticing one side of what is,
you're like looking for the truth of everything,
and that's what gets you into that state.
Yeah, when I think of awe and wonder,
I think of being present,
like if you're present enough,
and you just see the leaf on the tree,
that could inspire awe and wonder,
but it requires like a level of attention
that kind of alludes,
the way that we live our lives, right?
Like you have to really, really be practiced in that
or habitual in it
There's another parable that I came across
that I found incredibly useful as a way to live.
And this one also came from the Kalaba.
And it's the idea that
all of creation was originally
this intact divine vessel.
It was all intact, and then it broke,
the vessel broke.
And the world that we're living in now
is the world after the breakage.
And yet the shards of this vessel
are scattered everywhere around us.
And so what we can do,
we're still living in the broken world,
but we're living in a world where you can bend down
and pick up these shards of light.
And I love this as a way to live because
it's like a way of making sense of the tragedies
that are still an always part of this world,
but yet being able to turn in the direction
of joy and beauty, because you're not denying the tragedies,
you're not believing that a utopia is gonna come,
but you're still able to bend down and pick up
the shards of light that you personally notice.
And we're all gonna notice different ones,
but they're yours for the taking, yours to pick up.
Yeah, that's really beautiful.
But there's also packed into that a little bit of
a lament of what once was, or could have been,
had it not shattered.
That's true.
But I don't know a way to live without that lament,
when you look at the tragedies in the world,
like you have to make space for the lament also.
Sure.
Otherwise you're just living with blinders, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
Is this attunement attunement to bittersweetness trainable?
Like you can take the bittersweet test
and see where you score on it.
And certain people are obviously more attuned
or receptive to this than others,
but to the extent that appreciating bitter sweetness
or cultivating it, or kind of synthesizing
all the different colors of your experience
into some kind of creative offering
and making sense of it for yourself,
seems to be something that anybody can do.
And even if they score lower on that test,
they could increase their score.
And perhaps like,
elevate the richness of their life experience in so doing.
Yeah, so there are gonna be some people
who are born into the world
with that high sensitivity trait,
and they're probably gonna tend
in this bittersweet direction from the beginning,
then there's gonna be a lot of people who
just by virtue of life experience,
come to more of a bittersweet awareness over time
once they've-
Things happen in their life.
Things happen.
Jar 'em out of their lack of empathy or whatever it is.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
And for people who aren't there yet but would wanna be,
I think it's just a matter of turning your awareness
in your direction...
I'm sorry, turning your awareness in certain directions.
That's scary though.
Well, it's scary if you think that by doing that,
you'll never come out again.
And that's what I hear from a lot of people.
They're like, I'm afraid if I go there,
I won't be able to come out.
And yet there's no reason that that should be so
because these two states are always paired, right?
It's joy and sorrow.
So there's no reason you have to stay in one state.
It's more just a sense of being able to tell the truth
about everything that's happening or everything you observe.
Yeah.
The fear-
But why do you think it's scary?
I mean, I just think you're asking people
to confront painful past emotions
or to look objectively at stuff
that they've kind of worked hard to build walls around.
So that prospect of deconstructing those walls,
and really grappling with some past trauma
or something that occurred or whatever,
that you've kind of really tried hard to like move away from
requires a certain level of courage,
and I think it is frightening for a lot of people.
Like I know a lot of people who have built walls around
certain pains in their life
and by dint of that are able to kind of safely navigate
through their life but they wanna stay in that lane.
If you say, listen,
you're missing a huge growth opportunity
or a certain level of enriching life experience
by ignoring that, you should look at it.
And if you work through it,
like your life is gonna open up in ways
you can't possibly imagine.
Intellectually, they may understand that,
and I can kind of see that arc awaiting that person.
But for a lot of people, it's like,
that's fine, I hear you, but I'm not gonna do that.
And you've had that.
I mean, your story about your mom, on a certain level,
like illustrates this for me.
Like what I read in that was a certain
kind of affect in your mother,
she had her own painful experiences growing up,
and that very much informed how she interrelated with you
at times in very unhealthy ways.
But could you have been able to get your mother
to kind of confront her past trauma
so that you could have had
a healthier relationship with her?
That seems like a very steep mountain decline.
Yeah, no, I think people are at different points
along where they are in their lives,
and sometimes you're not ready at a certain moment
and you are 10 years later.
And I guess another thing...
Sorry, just to go back,
that's an interesting question with my mom,
'cause I've often thought,
would there have been a way to have her be open to that
if I had thought about how to get there, to do that.
Can you explain a little bit,
like tell a little bit of that story.
The story, yeah.
So I had a really
intensely close relationship with my mother growing up.
It was a kind of garden of Eden type of childhood.
She was incredibly loving, devoted, warm,
amazing company, we really loved each other's company.
Yeah, it was really quite wondrous.
But my mother had passed trauma was of her own,
and this made it so that when I became an adolescent,
she had a really terrible time,
especially because I was the youngest child.
She had a really terrible time with my growing up,
and becoming independent and having different ideas
and different life experiences,
and her reaction to that was incredibly difficult,
to say the least.
And I had a lot of trouble with it too.
Like I felt like I didn't use these words and in those days,
but it was a kind of like casting out of the garden of Eden.
Like suddenly the mother that I had known all my life
had transformed into a hostile person.
Where there was kind of a choice,
I could either still be with her and still be a child,
and be loved or I could grow up and develop and be myself,
and be cast out.
And I don't think I ever really questioned the choice
so I went and moved in a separate direction.
But the casting out part was like incredibly,
incredibly painful,
and my way of dealing with it because I'm a writer,
and I'd loved writing since I was four years old,
I wrote everything down into these diaries that I kept,
and went off to college.
And at the end of freshman year, for some reason,
I had to stay on campus for a few extra days
and my parents came to take my stuff home.
And just as they were getting ready to leave,
and they're like leaving with all my suitcases,
I take my diaries and I hand them to my mother.
And I thought at the time,
like I truly on a conscious level,
I thought I was just giving them to her for safe keeping,
I didn't have a place to store them at school.
And I never thought that she would read them,
on a conscious level,
but of course she did and whatever I had written there,
and I say whatever, 'cause I've never read them again since,
but whatever I had written there,
kind of like put the final nail in the coffin
of our relationship.
And so for the decades after,
we were still seeing each other at holidays
and doing all the regular family stuff,
but the relationship really was never the same again,
and it was like,
it was a loss for me that,
for years I couldn't even talk about
my mother without crying, I couldn't mention her name.
But I will say there's been this amazing rap posh mom.
Now my mother is Alzheimer's and,
she only has a few conversational lanes that she can travel,
but when she's on those lanes, she still feels like herself.
And she has completely forgotten all the difficult years
we had, she's forgotten them.
And so all this time through my adulthood,
I had always been asking myself,
that childhood that you remember as being so wonderful,
like maybe it wasn't really true,
maybe that was just like a child's misperception,
but now the mother of that childhood has come back.
And I realize like
we still are that way,
the relationship we have now is the same relationship we had
when I was a kid.
So that's been a kind of amazing.
Such an interesting story,
and certainly there's bitter sweetness in it, of course.
Oh yeah, yeah.
So much.
But the idea that you were faced with this choice
of either reverting into a childlike state,
or just becoming the person that
your mother actually wanted you to be,
put you in an impossible situation,
without her being consciously aware of
the kind of psychic toll that that would place on you.
And then the bittersweetness
of never really fully reconciling that later, right?
I mean, I read it as somebody who,
because of her past traumas and pain
that she hadn't adequately worked through,
there's this transference, like she wants you to be safe.
She wants you to be upwardly mobile and all of these things.
And she lovingly drives you
on this kind of ambitious journey
to achieving all these amazing things.
But as you achieve them, of course, separation occurs.
And that's a threat to this bond that she has,
that is so meaningful.
For her, that is in part driven by the pain of her past
that creates this unhealthy soup where she's transferring
so much of her identity onto you,
and you're as a young person having to shoulder that burden.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's funny I'm actually gonna
amend something I said before,
because I think I said a minute ago that,
I had never really considered doing anything
other than growing into a separate person,
but actually I'm not sure that's quite right,
because I do remember many times saying to myself,
like I loved her so much.
All I wanted was for her to be happy.
So I felt like, well, maybe I should do some of these things
that she's asking, so that she can still be happy,
which is a very difficult thing.
Right, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And did you have a sense of her self-awareness
around any of this or just, no?
I don't think so.
Yeah, I don't really know.
I don't think there was so much of it,
but what I will say happened, excuse me, over the years.
And especially during the time I wrote this book,
as I told you, it used to be that I couldn't
talk about her at all without crying.
And I wrote her story, I wrote the story in the book,
and I was like really worried about what was gonna happen
when I would go out and do interviews about the book.
I thought, I won't be able to speak about this
without breaking down.
And despite everything I'm saying in the book
about being comfortable with all our emotions,
I didn't really wanna do that.
So I didn't know what would happen (laughs).
But I remember talking to somebody about this dilemma,
and he said to me,
talk to me when you're done writing the book,
because you might actually resolve some of these issues.
And at the time he said that, I thought, oh my gosh,
that's never gonna happen.
But in fact, that's exactly what happened.
There's just a sense of peace
that I now have with everything that happened.
I don't know, just so much love for her
and understanding of it all and,
like, wishing that it had been different, but excuse me,
but I don't know, that's just a complete reconciliation.
Well, that's the beauty and the gift
of reckoning with your bitter sweetness, right?
Like you can have some kinship with Leonard Cohen,
who I'm sure similarly was having,
conflicting emotions and was in some sort of pain
and he was trying to work through it.
So what does he do?
He writes a song about it, right?
You write a book about it,
and in the process of writing this book,
you find a way to heal and make peace with yourself,
and your loved ones and come out the other side,
like a more complete human.
And that goes to the very thesis of the book,
which is channeling your pain and
turning it into a creative offering.
So it's like a meta exam.
Like it's all very meta in that regard, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I know, that's true.
And I do wanna be careful to say like,
for anybody listening,
again, that we use that word creative
in a really general way.
So it's not like you have to go and write a book
or write a song or like be a Grammy award winner,
or something, it has nothing to do with that.
It's more just about going through a kind of transformation
of like taking the pain and transforming it
into something of meaning.
Yeah, well just confronting it and walking with it,
and finding a way to come to the other side
through whatever, modality suits you.
Yeah, and it's funny,
I've been trying to write this story for so many years.
Like I said this in the book,
I first started writing about it when I was in college,
and my creative writing teacher said,
"You're way too close to this story.
"You should like put it in a drawer
"and not take it out again for 30 years."
So it's been a long time, and now it's 30 years later, yeah.
You're too close to it.
But you're still so close to it,
but you're distant enough from it
that you could write about it
with some level of objectivity,
but the fact that it creates so much emotion in you,
it's still very present with you.
Yeah, it's still very present, but like
with a lot less turmoil than there used to be.
I experience very little turmoil now talking about it
because I really do feel such a sense of resolution
between us and between like my relationship to my mother
in my heart, is very different.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
From what it had been.
Yeah, beautiful.
On this idea of binaries,
heaven, hell, rich, poor, and the like,
there is this undercurrent in our society
around the pursuit of happiness, right?
It's in the declaration of independence,
like the pursuit of happiness.
And now we're in a happiness obsessed culture.
I think we're getting to a point where
we're maturely grappling with what happiness means
and trying to create a healthier relationship
with how to build that into our lives.
But in reading your book, I couldn't help but think,
what would happen if that phrase
in the declaration of independence said something like,
may you pursue longing or something like that.
May you grapple with your own bittersweetness.
Like if we had created a cultural priority
around a more nuanced relationship
with the conflicting emotions
about what it means to be human,
how would that percolate into our culture
and change our relationship with the darker side of things
that make the brighter things so much brighter?
Yeah, it's an interesting question.
I've thought about that
with the declaration of independence.
I mean, I enjoy being happy as much as the next person,
so I don't think happiness is the problem,
but maybe it's just how we define happy.
Maybe meaning would've been-
Happiness at the cost of everything else.
Yeah, and I think we end up interpreting happiness
as a kind of like hedonic type of happiness,
as opposed to a happiness where you feel
a deep sense of meaning in your life.
And I also think part of the problem is that,
we have such a separation of church and state,
which is great in most ways,
but it means that all these questions
that religion naturally grapples with,
like this existential longing that we all have,
we tend to relegate that to what you experience,
at church on Sundays,
as opposed to just thinking of that
as part of everyday life.
Hmm.
Yeah, but as we become more agnostic as a culture,
are we not adequately
in constructs where we are actively confronted with
grappling with these philosophical questions and-
Wait, say the question again.
Meaning, like
you're saying that the purview of that kind of inquiry
would be in the church or whatever spiritual tradition,
we've become a culture that's that seems at least,
from my perspective, like less interested
in those types of outlets.
And so where does that leave us in terms of,
how we're dealing with those bigger spiritual
and philosophical questions?
Yeah, that's the problem,
'cause we've always relegated it just to that.
So it was already bad enough when we relegated-
But we're not going there anymore.
But now we don't even go there.
So now it's kind of nowhere.
Because dancing with the stars is on and, you know?
Yeah, exactly.
I think we need to find ways of introducing this
into part of everyday discourse,
and you could see how much we long for it because
you look at,
to take my patron Saint of Leonard Cohen,
like there's a reason that his song "Hallelujah,"
was making people cry for years on end.
It's like the most covered song I think in history
or something like that.
People are relating to that.
As soon as they hear it, they open up to it.
So we need to be finding different ways of introducing this
into everyday life.
And I think part of that would actually be just,
proactively engaging with beauty more in everyday life,
like at work at school,
like actively encouraging people to bring in
things that they find beautiful or meaningful,
and be sharing those.
You don't even have to talk about bittersweetness so much
it's like through engaging with beauty,
all of that comes out.
How do you feel about
Jeff Buckley's rendition of "Hallelujah?"
Is that sacrilege?
It's not sacrilege at all.
I like it.
It's not one of my favorites, but I do really like it.
But no, I'm all for covers, it's okay.
He captures the bitter sweetness.
He sure does.
In his music, beautifully.
He really does.
I like the Rufus Wayne Wright one.
Oh yes, very good.
Yeah.
Sorry, I've forgotten about that one.
I think a good story to tell would be the story of Beethoven
that you share around that performance,
because that so kind of captures this idea of,
channeling that emotional experience into something shared.
Yeah.
That breeds that community piece, right?
Yeah, so Beethoven, one of his,
maybe his most famous work is "Ode to Joy,"
which everybody loves so much.
Maybe we could even play it somehow into the episode.
I'll drop it in.
Yeah, drop it in.
And "Ode to Joy" actually started out as a poem
by Frederick Schiller,
and Beethoven loved this poem because,
it expressed like all these ideals of love and brotherhood
that were really important to him.
So he labored for years,
I wanna say it was 30 years, maybe getting that wrong,
but like forever, to set this poem to music.
But during the time that he's working on it,
he starts to lose his hearing.
And he has all these other personal troubles.
By the time of the debut performance,
after all these years of creating "Ode to Joy,"
he's now totally deaf.
And yet he's like desperate for this music to be performed
the way he hears it in his head.
And so he stands on stage with the orchestra,
with his back turned to the audience,
and he's facing the orchestra.
And he's like throwing his body around
trying to direct them to play the music
the way he sees it in his mind.
He's standing next to the conductor.
(orchestral music)
Because he can't hear any of it,
he doesn't even realize when the music is actually over,
when they're done playing.
But when it's finished, there's a 20 year old soprano.
And she turns him around to face the audience,
who are so overwhelmed.
They're like standing up in their seats
with tears streaming down their faces,
and raising their hands and tribute to this man
who's given them this experience of longing,
which you listen to that music and it's an "Ode to Joy."
It's literally about joy.
And yet you can't help but hear the longing and the sorrow
that's like echoing in its notes.
It's just the most incredible,
that's what makes the music so incredible.
And in fact,
there is an economist at MIT,
whose name I'm forgetting right now,
but he did this fascinating study where,
he looked at Mozart Beethoven and list at their music.
And he read all the different letters
they had written over their lifetimes
and he coded the letters for emotions.
And he found that during the periods
when their letters had a lot of emotions expressed,
sorrow and longing and grief, and like that,
that was when they were composing
their most profound best works of art.
Wow.
Yeah, yeah.
There's just this incredible confluence there.
And I feel like we know it instinctively.
Yeah.
But we're not sure what to do with it.
And we don't wanna go deaf-
It's hard to like canonize it, like,
oh, this note and this note, it's more than that, right?
Like it's the performance of the music as well.
You have the story of the violinist, right?
Like when you are carrying a certain emotional resonance,
it gets translated into those notes in a certain way
that we immediately recognize, but you can't quite define.
And in telling that story about Beethoven,
it's very cinematic.
Like I imagine like, he's just,
like doing his thing with such dramatic physicality,
but because he can't hear he's completely detached
with how it's being received and perhaps even thinking like,
is this even working at all?
Or am I able to kind of get out of these musicians,
the performance that I hear in my mind,
only to find out that it is United and really just,
uplifted and connected this huge group of people.
And I think it's really profound example of
the power of sharing those types of emotions
and figuring out a way to create a container for it
that people can consume.
That really is this antidote to what is dividing us.
And it's like, I don't have to tell you,
it does feel so divided out there.
And I often despair of our ability to kind of
mend that division.
And it used to be when a tragic of event befell
the country or the world, we would feel like one,
we would feel like that's super organism.
And now it feels like when that happens,
everybody retreats to their corner and figures out
how to blame the other side for it.
And like, how do we move forward
as a functional, healthy society
with this sort of rift and dynamic
that doesn't seem to be going away anytime soon.
Yeah, I know.
And I mean, I don't have answers
anymore than anybody has the answer,
but I do think that one thing that
we could and should be doing is creating spaces for people
to truly be telling their stories,
but to have the stories not be attached
to policy prescriptions, or politics or anything like that,
just tell each other the stories,
just get to know each other on that elemental level.
Obviously like our social media platforms right now
are designed to do the exact opposite of that.
But sometimes like if we could have a social media platform
that would give people space to just share it all,
maybe it needs to be done anonymously.
Or something like that.
Yeah, something like that.
Yeah, it is...
Sorry, go ahead.
No, I was just gonna say,
not everybody wants to tell their story with a name attached
the way you do with a moth, but you know how-
Maybe there's a way to anonymize it.
Yeah, yeah.
Or have that option.
Yeah.
I think there's something about storytelling,
like honest, open, vulnerable storytelling
that is akin to this notion of bittersweetness,
and perhaps it emanates from the Vagus nerve as well.
Like when we hear somebody share a story
and we have the sense that that story is true to that person
and honest and authentically rendered,
that also breeds connection, right?
Like whether it's bittersweet or not like just,
the storytelling as a vehicle for connection,
and also learning, like it doesn't have to be prescriptive,
but it's more effective than a prescription
when whatever that notion is kind of wet into the narrative.
Like we, as human beings are able to kind of synthesize that
and then ultimately kind of hold onto it
and perhaps even practice it in our lives in a way that
is very different than if somebody said,
here's the five things that you need to do today.
We remember this story, we forget the listical.
And I think there's something really profound about
that as well that perhaps,
can be traced back evolutionarily,
back to the campfires of your, and the like.
Absolutely, I mean,
I actually think podcasts play a huge role in that.
I think part of the reason that podcasts have become
the amazing medium that they are is that,
they're touching into that campfire impulse that we have.
There's something about the voice in your ear
as you're listening, where you feel like
you're like bonded with all the other listeners
sitting around a campfire, it's connection.
Exactly, exactly.
Yeah, so there you go.
There's your next book.
(Susan laughs)
What are you working on now?
Are you on another seven year Jat to the next one?
Well, I mean, I probably will be at some point,
and I have two different book ideas that I'm playing with,
but I actually wanna start a podcast also.
So I'm probably gonna be doing that in the next year.
And that's gonna be my next big project.
Oh, that's exciting.
Can you say more about that
or is that under wraps right now?
It's under wraps right now,
but I'll definitely let you know when it's ready,
it probably won't be until 2023.
So what is it that you want
people to get out of "Bittersweet" the most?
Like if they're to take away one core idea.
I mean, I guess I'd say the idea of that,
whatever pain you can't get rid of
to make that your creative offering.
And then another large idea I would say,
and this applies to "Quiet" as well as to "Bittersweet" is,
the idea of there being ways of being in this world
that are not talked about
that are actually kind of hidden superpowers.
'Cause I hear now from so many people,
like the letters that I'm getting from people who have read
"Bittersweet" are so similar to the letters
I've gotten all these years from "Quiet" readers.
Like it's all these people saying,
I felt this all my life and either I never read words for it
or I never felt like it was okay to talk about
because it's not seen as the right way to be.
And yet there is a sense of it being a superpower
once you understand it as such.
Yeah.
I think it would be helpful to also share some words for
perhaps the extroverts out there
that have introverts in their lives.
Like maybe they have a kid who's introverted,
and they're struggling to understand why this person,
wants to be in their room and doesn't wanna go to the party.
Or I think from a parenting perspective,
I have a child who's very introverted
and it's been an education and a learning experience
to like even though I have introverted proclivities,
I still have some extra...
It's sort of like, I don't want to judge my child
because this is my child's choice
or this is what this person needs
to recharge the battery in terms of like,
how we parent and how we think about
supporting the introverts in our life.
Oh yeah, I mean, there's so much to say there,
but I mean, the first thing as you're saying is,
to just really understand like where your child
or spouse or whomever it is, is coming from,
and what do they need to be happy.
With children I think the fear often is that
if they're not kind of out there socializing enough
that they're not gonna like get enough of the bounties
that life has to offer.
So one thing to know is that like the research shows that
if your child has one or two close friends,
that's what they need.
Like if your kid has no friends at all,
that's when you should be concerned.
But if they have just a few friends,
and if they're happy with that, then that's fine.
I mean, for all introverts, there's the question of
if a person wants to stay home from a party or something,
is that because of a true preference
of how they wanna spend their time,
or is it out of a sense of fear or discomfort?
Sure, right.
And like with a child,
if you think it's fear or discomfort,
then that's when you can be a really helpful parent
in helping them to develop strategies and work through that.
But if it's just preference
of how they wanna spend their time,
then you wanna make sure they don't become too isolated,
but you also wanna honor their preference.
Yeah, that becomes very nuanced and difficult
because is it a preference or is it just,
you're afraid of trying something new?
Like you need to get pushed a little bit out into the world,
and learn new things and try things and fail and all of that
to Susan David's point of emotional resilience.
Like you can't procure that in a vacuum.
Yeah, and the answer to that,
like if you sense that it's fear or discomfort,
that's standing in the way,
the answer to that for parenting,
but also for our own selves is to expose your child
or yourself to the thing that you fear,
but to do it in very small steps so that it's manageable
so your child has small wins as they go.
So like a lot of introverted kids just for example,
are a little iffy about swimming
when they're first introduced.
And the answer is not to like throw them in the water.
It's more to say, okay,
let's go to the pool on a day when it's super quiet,
we'll go like late on a Tuesday evening,
and you're gonna dip your toe in the water, and that's it.
And then we're gonna celebrate and we're gonna go home.
And then you go back the next day and you do a little more
and a little more and a little more,
and little by little, they come to love it.
And then you can't tell the difference between them
and the kid who just jumped in from the beginning.
But it's like, a lot of times,
introverted kids need a longer runway that they travel down
before they take off and fly,
and they need to know that you are with them on the runway
and admiring them and respecting them
as they travel that runway.
Right.
Yeah, that's really good advice.
I like that.
The final thing I wanted to ask you about is this idea
of being so good in your particular role,
professionally as an introvert,
but inevitably getting promoted into a role
that requires extroversion, which is the story of your life.
Like to write this book about,
introversion, to be an introvert,
and then to become the public facing persona
behind this idea and this movement,
have foisted you onto the public stage where
now it's kind of your job to like be extroverted in public.
And having to kind of learn a new set of skills.
And I think it's common probably in less extreme examples
of people who excel at their job,
and then suddenly they get promoted into a role that
requires a completely different skill set that is
at odds with who they wanna be or what they're good at.
Yeah, okay.
So I mean, the first thing I would say is that,
when that happens, that's really the moment when you know,
whether you love and care about your work or not,
because it's one thing to have to go outside
your comfort zone in the service of work that you love.
And it's another thing to have to do it
for a job that you don't actually care about that much.
So like, I care so much about what I'm doing
and I love writing so much.
And these ideas that it's like worth it to me
to go through the parts that are more of a stretch.
So in some ways introverts can see that as an advantage
that they're less likely to get stuck in the wrong job
because it's just gonna be too painful at the end of the day
when they get promoted.
But also, so the psychologist, Brian Little,
talks about this a lot, the idea that
in the service of work or people we care about,
we can and do and should sometimes step out of character,
but you have to do it in a way that honors your own self.
And you have to give yourself lots of restorative niches
to come back.
So like, I do that all the time.
Like when I go out on trips,
and I'm giving talks or interviews or whatever,
I spend so much time afterwards ordering room service
and just like chilling in the hotel.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's like you can't wait to get back
to the hotel room and be alone.
Yes, yeah.
And I really like honor that time,
and I guard it really carefully.
And then I feel like I'm lucky
'cause I also get to spend a lot of time doing my work
is just like sitting at a cafe writing.
So I do think it's worth asking oneself
like if you get to a point where your work is having you
constantly doing things that are outside your comfort zone,
it might be the wrong place for you.
But if you can get it to a manageable place,
and it's in the service of something you care about,
then it's okay.
Yeah, if you being like this public facing person
on the subject of bittersweetness or introversion,
meant that you couldn't write anymore,
because now you're running a large organization,
that's trying to foster these ideas.
That probably would not be something you would want,
that would be too high of a cost.
Way too high of a cost.
Even if it would make you super successful,
and push these initiatives through and change the world,
it's not within your constitution to do so.
Yeah, exactly-
And having that self-awareness to recognize that.
Exactly, exactly.
I feel like it's not my constitution, it's not my calling.
It's not what I feel like I should be doing.
Yeah, I am super careful about that
when I go and do these public facing things.
And is it non-anxiety producing for you now
because you're so practiced at it?
So it's not like extremely an anxiety producing anymore
the way it used to be for me, really not at all.
I feel like I've overcome that, but I would still say that,
a morning in which I'm looking at a day full of publicity
versus a morning where I'm looking at a day full of writing
with my laptop,
those were completely different mornings-
Two different experiences.
Yeah, of course.
Two different experiences, yeah.
I don't know, maybe everybody feels that way.
But I feel like it's probably more intense...
The difference between those two
is probably more intense for me.
Like I think I read actually that you,
I'm I right about this,
that you spend your mornings doing exercise and,
writing and contemplative things.
The first part of the day.
Yeah, and then you do podcast interviews
and things like that later.
And when I read that, I thought that's really interesting.
I don't think that would work for me because,
if I knew that I had the public facing side
happening later in the day,
I don't know that I would be able to enjoy as much
the writing and contemplate stuff.
It spoils the other stuff earlier in the day.
Yeah, yeah.
That makes sense.
But it sounds like you don't experience that.
No, it definitely,
like public speaking creates a lot of anxiety for me,
but like doing podcasts less so,
and it's something I could do it in the morning too,
but I need that time for...
That's a recharge the battery time, right?
Like if I don't recharge the battery,
then when I come in to do this other stuff,
like I'm just not at my best.
So I have to protect that time for self-care.
And that doesn't mean that I always do it perfectly
or that I don't make exceptions,
'cause life intervenes and all of that.
But I try really hard to like,
that's how I preserve who I am,
I think, the whole thing.
And it's a privilege, not everybody can have that, you know?
Right, absolutely.
And I recognize that,
but it's pretty fundamental to kind of how I do things.
Yeah, no, that makes sense.
And I have my...
You'll appreciate this.
Like my home office
is a shipping container
that we kit it out into like an office.
So it's just like a writing office
with bookshelves and things like that.
And that's where I kind of can work at home.
So it's customized on the inside and has an air conditioner
and all that kind of stuff.
But it's literally a shipping container.
And when we were kind of figuring out
how to tweak it and customize it,
the kind of contractor that we hired to like help us with it
he's like, "Well, you're gonna want a big window
"and you should do, and it should be like this,
"let all the sunlight in."
I was like, "No, I don't want any window."
I literally want to have the experience
of being in the womb.
Like to feel on some level on a primal level,
like that's what makes me feel safe and protected.
Yeah, I know, I totally understand.
And then he still put a little window in,
and then I hung a shade over it and so I can black it out.
Anyway.
I hope that office designers are listening to that.
(Susan and Rich laughing)
'Cause they're all like, you're crazy,
you're gonna want this.
I'm like, I'm telling you I'm not gonna want it.
All right, well, any last thoughts for the
introverts out there grappling with bittersweetness?
(Susan and Rich laughing)
Before we wrap it up.
Yeah, I think we can wrap it up really just to understand.
I don't know, just that my view of life.
I don't know if I've said this already,
so edit this out if I have, but-
Lay down the truth right now.
My life philosophy is that there are
different kinds of superpowers that exist in this world.
And usually we're each only granted one or two of them.
And like we know this from all the movies, right?
There's like "Lightsabers,"
and then there's like "Spiderman" and "Incredible Hulks"
and all these different ways of being powerful in the world.
And so for people who are born with more of
a bitter sweet way of being, or an introverted way of being,
and a sensitive way of being,
these are superpowers that where you're like
in the stage of the movie,
you're like Luke Skywalker before he knows
that he has the force basically,
because your culture isn't teaching you about the superpower
that you naturally possess, but it's there.
It's just yours to discover.
I think there's something really powerful too,
about that quiet person who is really grounded.
There's a center of gravity and kind of an anchor
to that person who knows who he or she is.
And is really comfortable in that quiet space
that is perhaps exponentially
more powerful than the boisterous person who's,
really loud and perhaps charismatic, but unable to kind of
have the resonance that that quiet powerful person
can impart.
Yeah.
I think that's right, and like I often tell people,
'cause the quieter people are always concerned about,
how do you show up in a meeting and still have presence,
especially when everybody's talking, being very dominant?
But there's a way where if you're speaking from
a sense of conviction, people know it,
like they feel it right away,
and that's what carries the power.
So the answer is not to try to become
a louder, more dominant person,
the answer is more to get in the habit of understanding
what you truly believe, and speak what you truly believe.
And then people feel that.
That's where the power comes from.
There you go, beautiful.
Thank you.
No, I appreciate it.
The work that you do and the wisdom that you share
with the world is really powerful.
And it's obviously changing millions and millions
of people's lives.
And I think these are really important topics and subjects
that previously, perhaps we were too afraid to talk about
and you've made it a thing.
And I just wanted to publicly thank you for that.
Oh, my God.
And can't we just see what you do next.
Well, thank you so much and such a treat
to get to meet you in person.
And I just love the work you do.
So thank you.
Thank you, pleasure and the honor is mine.
So come and talk to me again sometime.
I would love it.
Cool, peace.
(upbeat music)
(drum rolls music)